it didn't look like much of a halt in
fighting in the Syrian border town of
Rassilon despite the agreement between
the Turkish and American presidents and
soldiers from the Turkish back forces
were posting pictures of themselves
still battling inside the town one
Syrian asked me when does the ceasefire
come into effect the Turkish insist it's
just skirmishes but the country's
president invited a group of foreign
reporters including Sky News to tell
them if the Americans don't pull back
the Kurdish forces within five days
there'll be a lot more bis now but if
this promise in any way or form is not
kept the minute the 120 hours ends our
operation peace spring will continue
from where it left off the president was
meeting us as more horrifying pictures
were circulating the United Nations says
it's investigating how these children
got their injuries after accusations
that chemical weapons like white
phosphorus have been used by Turkish
forces over the past few days
these images are highly distressing this
little boy was splashed across two
British newspapers but the pictures from
a Kurdish online outlet are very
difficult to verify
especially after most independent
journalists left North Syria but if
chemicals have been used it would
constitute a war crime but the Turkish
president left his dorm of actually
palace having vehemently denied his
forces used chemical weapons he told
reporters he's fighting on two fronts
and one is the propaganda battle all the
journalists were given a booklet of
information called myths and facts
it's packed full of pictures which it
describes as either fake or real all
part of what the Turkish presidency
insists is a disinformation campaign
against its military operation there are
no pictures of the children but there
are several claiming to show chemical
attacks including this one which was
actually taken in Mosul in Iraq in 2017
during American operations but Kurdish
officials continue to accuse turkey of
war crimes this is one incident a hit on
a civilian convoy heading to wrassle on
which the Kurds and Amnesty
International accused the Turkish forces
of carrying out amnesty called the
attack a shameful disregard for life but
both the president and the Turkish vice
president in an exclusive interview with
Sky News vehemently denied their forces
were responsible so we are there for
humanitarian reasons have been accused
of bombing their civilian convoy how is
that of course not providing
humanitarian that's totally a lie that's
not true at all his boss the Turkish
president is off the same view and says
it's not a war he's fighting terrorism
he's determined to get his buffer zone
along the border with Syria and he's
made it clear he expects his NATO allies
to back him Alex Crawford Sky News
Istanbul